eric boone sending that line up against
the young right-hander logan gilbert
this will be his tenth start on the year
two and two record the era just over
four but he's been pitching a whole lot
better lately look at our pitcher
scatter report he was a first rounder in
2018 the 14th overall pick and he's
proud of his fastball and he should be
because he's got a good one he throws it
about 61.9 percent of the time and it
averages 95 to 97 miles an hour oh and
by the way he's got a really good slider
too he throws that 21 percent of the
time batting average against that pitch
only 116.
swing and a miss mark holds on good
start for gilbert
six pitches all of them the fastball 97
miles an hour staying on the inner half
of the plate in the late swing by le
mayhew here's the pitch on the way
swinging a drive straight away center
field but fraley going back to his left
near the warning track jake is there has
a lot of room and he makes the catch
judge
flies out and logan gilbert keeps him in
the ballpark here's gary sanchez the
catcher the pitch on the way swinging
it's popped up left side of the infield
foul territory coming down the line kyle
seeger battling the sun he's there and
he makes the catch halfway home and it's
a one two three top of the first inning
for the kid jordan montgomery gets a
start today it'll be his 17th a three
and three record the air raid just over
four at 4.17
look at our pitcher scouting report on
monty maybe the frustration is settling
in a little bit he mentioned after his
last start against the new york mets
that maybe it would be better to give up
line drives i i don't necessarily agree
let's stick with it you've been doing a
good job getting keeping the hard hit
percentage down it's only 30.
34.7 percent seventh in the american
league so he's doing a lot of good
things and we talked about the
possibility for a sweep of this series
it's a big road start for him he hasn't
pits well on the road 5.53 era on the
road
crawford lines that to center gardner
played him perfectly one down there's
third baseman kyle seeger celebrated his
10th anniversary in the big leagues all
over the mariners yesterday swinging a
drive straight away center field gardner
going back to the warning track a little
bit of room leaps up and it's gone
goodbye baseball
kyle seeger with a home run just over
the wall and straight away center field
brett gardner wanted to bring it back
but he came up short
kyle seeger with his 16th home run of
the season and it gives the mariners a
one-nothing lead here in the bottom of
the first inning that's a philo of 105
402 feet straight away center field
gardner thought he had a chance to bring
it back in the ballpark but it's over
the fence for kyle
here's the pitch hung on popped up
shallow left center field going out
torres coming in la castro and it's
going to be labor torres to make the
catch as france pops it up stan smokes
that to left field
absolutely blistered skates to the wall
and stanton has a leadoff double that's
really nice piece of hitting for
giancarlo stanton when you have to gear
it up for 97 or 98 miles an hour
and then you're going to get a slider
and just really sits there it's almost
like a bp fastball here we go gilbert
looks in has the sign for murphy two on
two away the three two pitch the gardner
swinging a ground ball left side
crawford to his right to backhand it off
balance thrown up first and it's in time
to get gartner what a play by the gold
glover j.p crawford that will retire the
side and logan gilbert gets out of a
second inning jam what a play by jp we
go to the bottom of the second here's
second baseman dylan moore checks the
runner at first and the next off of the
way swinging to drive deep into the gap
and left center field gardner going back
warning track to the wall goodbye
baseball dylan moore
with his eighth home run of the season a
two out two run home run
out to the pen
second home run already of the afternoon
for the mariners and it's now the
mariners three
and the yankees nothing and the mariners
doing the bombing early in the ball game
another off speed pitch it's a hanger in
the middle of the plate and he barrels
it up exit velo of 104
409 feet that's great to see
looks it has a sign for murph now the
wind-up and again the 2-2 devoid swing
and a miss and a breaking ball down and
away for strike three that is strikeout
number five for young logan gilbert and
counting and it's a one two three the
wind-up band the one-two pitch swing and
a ground ball down the third base line
backhanded by seeger quick throwing a
hop to first white online and in time to
get her shell a holy smokes what a play
by gold glover third baseman kyle seeger
quickly to his right he knew in his
inner clock he wasn't going to have a
lot of time he made the transfer as he
was still going to his right
and that throw was right on the money a
one-hop strike over to ty france to get
urchella what a play 11 in a row retired
by logan gilbert and the 2-2 on the way
to gardiner fastball swing and a miss
for strike three and that's going to
retire the side six strikeouts for logan
gilbert gilbert has retired the last 12
yankee hitters in a row how about that
judge only hit it giancarlo stanton lead
off double second inning the 1-1 pitch
swinging a ground ball right back it
knocks in and out of the glove of
gilbert who gathers himself and the ball
he runs halfway to first base and
underhand tosses to france to retire the
side in order
logan gilbert has worked
six scoreless one hit inning so far
today against the bombers we go to the
bottom of the six three nothing mariners
good battle here from sanchez
gilbert has retired 15
in a row he's got to go fastball right
it's been his bread and butter pitcher
all day
he does sanchez hits it hard for right
to shore
crawford will throw him out and gilbert
wins
an 11-pitch battle
with gary sanchez oh great at bat for
gary sanchez again nothing to show for
it but you got to give this young kid
credit well here is giancarlo stanton
who has the only hit today for the
yankees
swing and a miss for strike three
vicious slider and stanton is left
baffled he is having a ball game man
eight strikeouts
17 consecutive retired now you see why
he was number one 14th overall in the
2018 first year draft here's voight
gilbert's 3-1 pitch
swinging is popped up
shallow right center field dylan moore
is racing out here comes mitch haniger
and he makes the catch for out number
three
what a performance today under the
seattle sunshine by logan gilbert
a one-hitter against the yankees over
seven just sensational innings and he
retires the final 18 yankees hitters in
a row and that'll bring up right fielder
mitch haniger mitch one for three on the
day here's a drive deep to left
get it yeah
lead over the yankees here in the 8th
inning
19th home run for mitch his 48th rbi his
second hit today here's dj le mayhew
fastball on the way and it's inside and
that hits le mayhew on the leg
and lemay you running up the first base
line looking to his left at graveman
and not quite sure maybe their bad blood
in the past looks in has the sign from
tom murphy le mayhew lead here's the
pitch the judge swinging the ground ball
to third seeger's got it down the second
there's one reeling at first and the
ball game is over the mariners shout out
the new york yankees this afternoon four
to nothing a three-pitcher combined
one hit shutout young logan gilbert was
absolutely sensational we got some
issues down here they're still upset
with gregman and kendall not backing
down from any of them no just a few
words at the end of it